after there were some lawsuits the splc
took down their slander of me because
they were getting sued left and right
but chris matthews of msnbc on his prime
time program
said that there's a rise of racist
right-wing tea baggers
with groups like we are change and i'm
like wait what are you kidding me so i
made sure to doorstep and to confront
chris matthews face to face and i was
like hey chris
you called my independent news
organization that that
strives to do independent reporting a
right-wing racist
teabagging group explain yourself why
this is this is slander he's like i
never said that
i was like yeah i was like yes you did
he was like no i didn't i don't know i
don't know what you're talking about
and i'm like okay here wait let me show
you the clip i literally pulled up the
clip
and as he's watching it he's like oh
crap i'm like
answer your answer right now because you
slandered you lied about
me to the entire world answer to it
right now
uh he had no answer he was running away
scurrying away and i'm like
you know these people have no spines
they can't back up what they say
you can see the video right now we are
change chris uh
um oh sorry uh matthews chris matthews
i was confusing him with chris martinson
uh
chris but yeah yeah he sounds like my
bosses
every time i would confront them about
something they said they'd be like i
didn't say that
i didn't say that i'm like well i
recorded you in fact um
early on this when they really started
going after me it just
blinds that i was so confused um you
know i've had three years of great
relationships with my bosses made no
sense
so i i i did start recording to protect
myself but i actually emailed them
sound bites of themselves to prove to
them that i was recording them and that
they were lying
oh you're saying you didn't say this
here's your recording
that you said that and here's the thing
they continued to go after me even even
after i did that but i have a funny
story of how i first heard about you
it wasn't until after this started
happening that i first heard about you
because i was you know i was zoned into
this the corporate media life i don't do
alternative media like you guys right
but uh so i had just i had it it was
like two weeks after i had covered dr
veron's hydroxychloroquine
and they they came after me like none
other and i i went
i went to climb a mountain i actually
because i do my hobby is is producing
these songs that i write because i
songs come to me through inspiration and
so i was like let me just do something
with these um so last year i just
started doing something with the music
that i wrote
anyway i i had gone to colorado i had
written a
song like with the metaphor of mountains
in it so i wanted to shoot a music video
in the in the mountains uh like this is
my hobby let's go all out let's uh let's
film a music video too so i'm climbing
the mountain with my cameraman
um and i was telling him about this
insanity that i'm dealing with at fox
and uh how i'm having to record my
record them to protect myself
and um and he was like yeah he's like
you should just get out of there as soon
as possible and
and do be just like tim pool just do the
temple thing
and uh i was like who's that and and so
then he told me
about your youtube and then i saw this
huge
cult following you have and i was like
wow and then i started watching you
and and i was like wow he does great
youtube shows like this is
this is way more informative than our
newscast well now
uh i'm trying to get more and more
journalists to do original reporting
and so we just had a conversation with
one guy who's going to do a lot of
original policy and culture stuff
and it's going to be fantastic because
the i can't i can't count on these other
outlets to do it
you know it's it's it's funny how we
read a lot of these outlets and we
assume the news is true if it makes
sense
right cnn can put out a story write a
story today china sends 28 warplanes to
invade taiwan china sent 28 warplanes to
invade taiwanese airspace
crossing over this like demarcation line
or something and i just assume it's true
even though i know cnn lies all the time
i mean it's foreign policy why wouldn't
it be true it's the gallo man amnesia
effect the only problem is something
else
it's gel man and cognitive dissonance
because i can come out all day and night
and say cnn lies left and right they're
full of garbage
and then when i see a news story about
foreign policy i can only assume it's
true i'm like are they lying about this
now
well you know what probably but what am
i supposed to do
it's incredible when you really think
like how much
how much of the news i'm seeing is even
factual
and i think a lot of this a lot of it is
not
the journalists being i mean a lot of
journalists like i said i think
are it's a combination of of lazy
overworked
uh understaffed and and just
journalists who don't want to seriously
dig in i think
journalists are very easily manipulated
by their sources and i think some of
these
fake news stories we're getting are from
aggressive
sources who know how to manipulate the
reporter
have you ever read the book trust me i'm
lying by ryan holiday
no i haven't that guy's a genius you
should definitely check out that book
he talks about how easy it was to
manipulate the media one of my favorite
stories
from this guy ryan holiday check him out
he's awesome he's got a podcast was it
the daily stoic
yeah he's amazing dude he was promoting
um this guy tucker max
that's his name right tucker max i'm not
sure okay well was that his name luke
um i i don't know i'm looking yeah all
right we're getting a yes from another
camera
so uh he was promoting this guy and so
we came up with a really good idea
they bought a billboard and i could be
ruining i could be getting the story
wrong it's been a little while but
the story is basically this yeah they
put up a billboard
and then they personally vandalized the
billboard
then the next day he calls the radio
station and he goes i'm driving down the
street i see this billboard it's all
vandalized apparently this tucker max
guy's like a bigot and a misogynist
so then the local media was like oh what
happened somebody vandalized
so the media got on it reported this
story giving free press attacker max
and then i guess they organized the
protest against themselves
so that they could generate press for
his book or movie or whatever and it
worked
wow it is so incredibly easy to
manipulate the press and i think that's
one of the big problems
when the media is decaying struggling to
make money as the landscape changes
and they're easily manipulated by
activist groups it just becomes an
activist apparatus that's what it is it
either either it's going to sell
you know more waffles or whatever from
for from the from the
edgo corporation or whatever whatever
companies trying to sell so they got to
make the most punchy confirmation bias
news
or the activists have taken over like
the new york times you know we saw barry
weiss quit because she's like people in
new york times are like nervous and
it's being taken over by this
indoctrinate you know this these
indoctrinated this this cult
mentality and stuff so now what do we
get well when you read the news you're
probably just reading ideological
garbage
especially when it comes to domestic
stuff that's what it's been like for
millennia like i think about julius
caesar he'd go to battle and then he'd
write the history report about what the
battle was about he'd write about who
the enemies were if he even wrote about
him at all
and i mean we didn't even have what's
called a press until they invented the
printing press which is like 500 year
old technology the idea of a press
and then even in the last 80 or 100
years have we had it
be you'd be allowed to speak out against
your government
like vocally with the american democracy
before you just get killed or put in
prison but it but it is different
you know history being written by the
victor is not the same as
a massive media apparatus
writing things that serve a political
goal
in the end right if caesar was going out
telling everybody that it already won
the war before it started
or that you know making up lies to to
guarantee them and
manipulate the public that's more again
and i'm sure yeah they would do that
right exactly
you want to control the population the
difference is uh
subtle i suppose but you make a good
point it's always about these powerful
groups that want to manipulate poor
people
keep knowledge away from them so they
can't rise up so they can't protect
themselves
and so they're working basically as
serfs
or i guess back in rome slaves for the
empire
i think it goes back to i mean
conspiracy alert
the bible lucifer the lightbringer who
gave
the technology of light to the people i
don't know that that he did that well
they call him the lightbringer
so i'm trying to think why would they
call him the lightbringer well well
did he give electricity to people like
zeus had electricity at that lightning
if you didn't read it you probably
shouldn't make assumptions about what
the story i'm all over the place
well if you look even at the history of
the printing press this was something
that was pushed back
by the establishment by the powers that
be that didn't want the printing press
because they didn't want people
reading certain scriptures certain
documents because it empowered
them and whenever we have new technology
come it gives us a small window a small
opportunity to actually talk to one
another to find out what the world is
really like and
one of the most important powers you
could have in this world is con
controlling the free flow of information
and then you could usually correlate in
the society how free
the press is to how free the people are
and if people
are are under a press that is tightly
controlled by special interest
by intelligence agencies by people like
udo uffket who
was a prominent german journalist who
openly talked about how the cia was
right in
writing press releases that the
mainstream media was just regurgitating
whenever you have a tightly controlled
mainstream media that just regurgitates
the talking points of the special
interest of the powers that be
you have a people that aren't free and
you expect me to do to do what research
the press release and actually write a
news story about it okay listen listen
i i'm busy i'm i've got ikea doing a
delivery later today
so i want to go home early let me just
copy and paste the press release from
joe biden
onto the website so i can leave already
heaven for but i have to actually fact
check the men
that's uh that's how newsrooms operate
basically yeah because if one of the
facts turns out to
make joe biden look bad that could
cast accusations at you as a journalist
that's right and and that's why i'm
putting out these recordings
especially the one that i just put out
tonight because i want to show
why reporter reporters self-censor
themselves to protect themselves they
want to avoid going through exactly what
i went through
a lot of reporters live in fear fear of
of losing their job or being
uh hurt some way by their bosses
sub stack do you have a sub stack yet
no maybe maybe you do that um you know
it's working out for glenn greenwald and
michael tracy
right okay someone was sending me
something about that
um people can throw you a couple bucks
and you just write
stories and then your your users you're
supported by your readers who expect you
to do a good job
and if you do a bad job you'll lose
their support now there's
there's there's a problem there too
obviously if you write a bunch of
articles talking about how trump is you
know god emperor obviously you'll get
trump superfans who will sign up and the
moment you say he's not
many of those people will leave so
there's still a confirmation bias
problem memberships as well
that's right that's what we saw with the
aclu see the aclu defended the right of
the uh
defended the right to free speech of the
unite the right people in
charlottesville
and they got attacked for it and
panicked they had gained
so many new members donating monthly
because they challenged trump on his
travel ban so then when they defended
unite the right
they started bleeding users like members
like crazy who are like oh you're
supporting bigots so then the aclu
flipped and now they're this weird
organization that
claims to protect free speech but very
much does not defend civil rights at all
we call it the anti-civil liberties
union
yeah because they they they've certainly
become a vile disgusting organization
that actually seeks to suppress rights
and not support them and the same is
true
for free press my favorite my favorite
one is free press.net
what do you think they're all about well
they had a big campaign to make sure
alex jones was banned from the internet
because you know that's what a free
press is all about
banning wrong think wow the modern era
is a creepy time
you know but i'm glad that we can have
these conversations the very least uh
for as long as we can have them
because you know we're constantly under
threat of getting banned a lot of people
don't think
they're like oh tim says he's gonna ban
it's never gonna happen it's like dude
we've already got a warning on this
channel we're seeing what they're doing
to stephen crowder
we're seeing what they're doing to
smaller smaller channels it just so
happens that i'm a bit more milk toast
than many of those people but it's only
a matter of time
the narrative must be protected at all
costs what youtube and many of these
other
uh big tech companies want is they want
to homogenize
perspective they want to get rid of
anything that falls outside of the
narrative so they can easily control it
it's like micah brzezinski said it's our
job to control
exactly what people think she said it
verbatim
let's just pull it up again so no one
can say i'm lying from grabian
our job is to control exactly what
people think oh she came out later and
said no no i meant
not shut up lady we know what you think
you are we know what you think you're
doing we know what msnbc is doing or cnn
they lie yeah and she uh her father was
a very prominent person that played a
very key role in american politics in
american geopolitics
sabinif brzezinski that was jimmy
carter's presidential advisor
a part of the trilateral commission
bilderberg council council on foreign
relations and
really pulled a lot of strings when you
look at organizations like the council
on foreign relations there's a reason
why they allow so many journalists a
part of their secretive club
there's a reason they have so many off
the record meetings between people in
high positions of power
and the mainstream media and they work
kind of in tandem here and that's why
you know we have to understand here
there's so much power there's so much
cause and effect by information and when
you could tightly control it
you could do so many amazing things but
you could also do so many
awful things and when you look at the
history of the mainstream media i mean
if there's a
if there's an honest good working
youtube moderator out there which i
doubt but if there is
just please please look at the record of
the mainstream media
and look how many times they were wrong
and look how many times independent
media has been
right calling things out small mom and
pop
operations have been calling things out
correctly
for so long we finally have the
opportunity to be heard
and that opportunity is closing down
every single day with
algorithms de-platforming
demonetizations there's so many things
standing in the way and that's why you
know what you were doing
with timcast.com what other people are
doing starting their own platform
starting their own services
uh and your guys's participation in it
is absolutely crucial because you need
to not only vote with your dollar but
vote with your attention
with your clicks with your shares and
and it means
everything and i really think we're
seeing that happen i think that
the ratings and the and the readers and
everything is
is moving away from the establishment
media to the
alternative media this is the era of the
independent journalists i don't think
we're the alternative media anymore i
think collectively we're getting more
more traffic aren't we exactly that's
right so
so even but they consider they i think
they would consider you
alternative but here's yeah but that's
like an old man saying get off my mind
exactly but and that who cares what the
establishment
anyone thinks because the viewers the
actual citizens
are gravitating to the truth seekers
yeah you know
i think one of the biggest problems that
we have in society
people getting scared of what the
establishment thinks who cares
literally who cares or having a hit
piece on them yes which now is a badge
of honor
now i see the mainstream media trashing
someone i'm going to be like okay well
let me do a little bit of research and
not believe in point blank because
there's usually an agenda to try to
trash or bring someone down
or even just an ego to egotistical push
to
bring someone down for for the algorithm
so there's a lot of manipulation
happening behind the scenes being aware
of it being conscious
being able to take a few moments to
breathe and take a step back and look at
the larger picture
is something that more and more people
need to do and sadly
you know the mainstream media doesn't
like that they don't want you thinking
they don't want you conscious they don't
want you in a state that you're not in a
constant
fear state that you're not in a constant
stress state that you're not in a
constant consumer state because bad
consumers is bad for business bad for
advertisers
bad for the overall agenda it's so
interesting the harder they push for
that that they're getting
the opposite of what they're trying for
it's freaking people out and causing
them to think for themselves and seek
out answers for themselves but there's
there's a there is a weird divide where
some people i think
know something's wrong but they refuse
to speak out because they're cowards
right there's a hundred percent in the
media absolutely
so uh you know what man i'd love for the
people who recognize what's happening to
finally step out
step up speak out uh be brave and
contact
james o'keefe 100 and expose corruption
and let me tell you
we've already heard from several
insiders in newsrooms who are uh
are saying they're ready to to kind of
follow in my footsteps
so there's going to be more uh exposes
are you are you
uh if if these people fall through and
look i'm going to be there for them
i know james is going to be there for
them like whoever
i'll hire everybody seriously there's so
many there's so many people who are
ready to hire you and donate to you and
support you if you want to
break away from this media which is
really a cult and
cults worship something and what they
worship is the narrative break
break free be a true journalist it's
really hard to be a true journalist in
the in the corporations in some
in some beats in some news beats you can
do great journalism like the crime beat
they would let me cover crime
no problem other other beats okay now
i don't know about that so much anymore
i mean uh there's this really funny
story where they said
that the the ant there's there's a lot
of memes going around about stop asian
hate and the perpetrators being
black men and this report i think from
nbc news said
but when we actually looked at all known
suspects in the media we found 75
were white and therein lies the problem
many outlets have straight up said they
will not reveal
the race of an individual if it would
you know produce a harmful stereotype or
contribute to one
so you want to cover crime don't be
surprised if you know there was this
moment in sweden
where a guy committed a crime and so the
media pixelated his face and then
changed the tone
behind the pixels because we want to
avoid racist stereotypes it's like
uh or recently it was the austin there
was a shooting in texas in the newspaper
didn't want to describe the suspect
that was that large that was that large
that people were looking for
that shot up a nightclub and and then
and the newspaper refused to even
to talk about who he was
i had a co-worker who did that in
minneapolis when i was with nbc
she covered a crime story this guy is on
the loose after committing a vicious
crime
at typically when we're doing it at the
end of the story
we say hey guys please look out for this
guy here's his full description call
police if you see him
she refused to do that part of the story
helping catch this criminal
because he was black
and she didn't want to she didn't want
to say
say a description like that and she now
works for cnn
oh wow cnn probably recruited her the
moment they heard that she did that they
were like that's the kind of
no but i'm not kidding they probably
said someone who will just say what
she's told to say without arguing
without needing to be bribed
i mean look you get a real journalist
and how much money you got to pay them
to to bend them you get an idea log and
you can be like we're actually docking
your pay because you're racist
please go tell the world and say okay
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time